welcome friends I'm Norah O'Donnell and
joining today in the Toyota greenroom is
New York Times bestselling author and
host of the happy herb podcast Gretchen
Rubin Gretchen uses science pop culture
and personal experiences to explore how
we can make our lives happier you have
so many best-selling books and so much
good information so talk about how can
we in 2019 make our lives happier well
one of the one thing that the scientists
and ancient philosophers would agree
that a key to happiness and probably the
key to happiness is relationships so if
you're thinking about 2019 a great thing
to start thinking about is how can you
broaden or deepen your relationships
whether that's going to a reunion
planning a party go into a party instead
of being like I'd rather to stay home
emailing a friend starting or joining a
group anything that is going to help you
connect with other people is probably
going to make you happier we reported
this morning that the World Economic
Forum now reports that 40 percent of
those under the age of 25 feel lonely
how closely is loneliness tied to
happiness
well loneliness is a tremendous
happiness stumbling block because again
relationships are a key part of
happiness and one of the things that's
important to think about if you're
feeling lonely is what kind of
loneliness are you feeling or do you do
you wish you had an intimate partner do
you want more friends do you want more
quiet companionship do you need a crowd
of friends people have different needs
in their lives and so really to get
clear on what you want I have talked a
lot of people who feel lonely if they
don't have an important animal in their
life they feel like I really want that
dog my life doesn't feel complete
without a dog so then you're thinking
like well maybe you need to move so you
can get a dog you want to think about
why you're feeling lonely and then take
steps to address it one of the things
you've talked about in your books I
think that's extremely helpful is
writing down your own what you call
12-person yeah Commandments explain that
so personal Commandments they're not
things like make your bed they're more
about principles about what's most
important to your deepest values and the
things that you really want to remember
so for instance one of mine is to accept
other people's feelings so so not to
constantly tell people what they what
they
thinking but like to accept the reality
of other people's feelings or one of my
more obscure ones to spend out I'm one
of these people that kind of saves
things like I'll buy a new white t-shirt
and then I won't wear it for six months
because I'm saving it or like I won't
use nice stationery because I'll hold it
back so I have to remind myself spend
out you use things up and this is also
true creatively like don't hold an idea
back put it out into the world and trust
that they'll be more so that's writing
your personal Commandments is a great
way to get clarity that's my husband
Syria with wine it's not you're buying a
lot of expensive oils keeping it in the
place you're supposed to drink it
exactly exactly exactly I use it up
spend out yes we share but I really I
really liked this 12 commandments I mean
there have been talk about Stephen Covey
in the house of course I'm talking about
writing your missions done but I think
lists are popular with lists and short
lists and so you write number one be
Gretchen yes yeah so what what I've
realized is that we can build a happy
life only on the foundation of our own
nature our own values our own interests
and when I try to be someone else it
never really works I have to remember
like be Gretchen like I mean number two
let it go yes that one resonated with me
right go no grudges no resentments move
on do it now yes right away it's the
easiest way so how do you suggest
someone create these 12 commandments you
know if it sit down I think it takes
time I mean I probably took me six
months because I had more than 12 in it
less than 12 it's really creative and
fun I think it's a really fun exercise
to come up with what these would be what
are the phrases that you keep telling
yourself whether it's like just do it or
you know enjoy the now and start keeping
a list and I think over time people
really do start to see that it
crystallizes you have so many helpful
hip tips which is why I want to really
kind of try and share as many as we can
great with everyone here on Facebook you
talk about habits manifesto what we do
everyday matters more than what we do
once in a while well I know you believe
that for exercise right this has been my
mantra for 5-mile run once every two
weeks it's not as good oh my motto to
myself is every damn day yes and sorry
for people don't like the word damn yeah
but in my mind even if you can get on
the treadmill for 10 minutes yeah it's
better than
nothing else what I'm really trying to
do is I'm trying to create a habit yes
so how important are habits in happiness
the thing is habits are like the
architecture of everyday life about 40%
of everyday life is shape I have it so
if you have habits that work for you
it's just much more likely that you're
gonna be happier healthier more
productive more creative if you have the
habit of exercise then you're not using
your willpower you're not making
decisions you're just have up and going
because every day you exercise so this
just happens on automatic pilot it's a
lot easier than fighting yourself every
day to try to get yourself to exercise
so habits can really make it easier to
do the things consistently that we know
are going to make us happier whether
that's getting enough sleep whether it's
giving a warm hello when people come and
go from our house whether it's stepping
away from our devices reading more all
these things are easier when they become
habits another one of your habits
manifesto you say when we give more to
ourselves we can ask more from ourselves
this is a fun one because we should
treat ourselves we should load ourselves
with healthy treats because when we give
more to ourselves we can ask more
because we all need to feel energized so
you don't want an unhealthy treat you
don't want that extra glass of wine or
the extra brownie or the expensive pair
of shoes what you want is like doing a
crossword puzzle or buying yourself
fresh flowers or getting on the Sun okay
that's my number one go-to right yeah
but when you give yourself those things
and don't do it as a reward don't sound
like I have to earn it I have to justify
you get it just because you want it and
because you get that massage it's
actually going to be easier to exercise
every damn day it's gonna be easier to
eat healthfully because you you're gonna
feel more replenished you're gonna get
energized I hear this so much about
relationships that people are in like
trying to change someone in your family
trying to change someone that perhaps
you're in a relationship well with
because you think if you can change that
person then you would be happier but
don't say we can't make people change
but when we change others may change yes
so if I I want my whole household to
have like a tender light-hearted
atmosphere I can't make other people do
that but if I'm more tender than
light-hearted if I lighten up then
everybody else will change too and I'm
sure you've seen this like when like
because I read a lot about outer org
intercom when one person becomes much
more orderly other people also just kind
of start to become more orderly because
of the example and also just because we
sort of catch behaviors from each other
and so the only person that we can
affect is ourselves we only person we
can changes ourselves but when we change
them relationships changed so you're a
changed part of it tell us about your
new book that's coming out yeah so in
March my book is called outer order
inner calm because for most people not
everyone but for most people out our
order contributes to inner calm kind of
more than it should it's sort of weird
and so it's all about why we feel that
way and then what are a lot of the
little quick easy things that we can do
to create outer order and then to
maintain it because we've all done the
thing where you clean out your closet
and a week later it suggests as about it
so give a specific example of how you
can create outer order so for example
you can follow the one minute rule so
this is anything you can do in less than
a minute do without delay if you can
hang up your coat instead of tossing it
on the floor if you can rip up in a
letter scan it realize you don't need it
and toss it and what this does is it
kind of gets rid of that scum of clutter
on the surface of life and then it's
it's extremely effective another one is
to use the test so Marie condos test
this does it spark joy I found that
didn't work for me because I'm like
these scissors don't really spark joy
but they're good they're fine I always
say like do you need it do you use it do
you love it
because sometimes I love things that I
don't need or use and sometimes I use
things that I don't really love but if I
don't need it use it or love it then I
probably can get rid of it so it's we
use the phrase in our house declutter
ization I don't think actually an actual
word should be though I love that word
yes but it's time for decluttering the
idea of like getting rid of what you
don't need or love or doesn't fit has
holes in it yes time to move on it's
better to have less stuff than more
stuff yes yes because it just becomes
overwhelming and fighting through those
things and then I'll see you're
surrounded by things that don't really
work it's like their broken umbrella why
do you have a broken umbrella are you
gonna get fixed no are you gonna use it
not really get rid of it if you had to
order in terms of happiness a couple of
different things in terms of what you
eat mmm
exercise sleep where would you put
those three things if you had to rank
them in order I think I would put sleep
first because if you don't have enough
sleep then you constantly it's hard to
exercise it's hard to eat healthfully
because you're just trying to Jack
yourself up on sugar and and you just
feel exhausted so I think I would put
sleep first and then I think I would put
exercise because when you're exercising
it's amazing it gives you more energy
but it also makes you feel calmer it
makes you feel more in self-command I
think them eating healthier follows from
the exid exactly I think they're all
critically important but yeah we've had
a number of reports we do them every
morning you know almost every morning on
CBS is wanting to talk about the
importance of sleep but yes I was
recently at a school visit because I
have three young kids and there was a
director of curriculum and he actually
teaches at Columbia he said the number
one thing you can do for your children
in terms of their happiness and
well-being is sleep yeah we are facing a
sleep crisis in this country and for
some that resonates with me because I
work early morning yes but I'm thinking
we're distracted by our devices where we
have them in our beds now you're
sleeping next to them that this is
creating this crisis of loneliness yeah
lack of connection with other people and
then how lack of happiness and health
effects yeah yeah no it's tremendous
here's an idea if you're having trouble
with sleep so for a lot of people they
just find it hard to get themselves into
bed they're all so anyway yeah I know
what time you get up in the morning yes
yes yes for a lot of people it's like
they're like I'll just check my work
email one more time or oh I'll just you
know start watch I'll just watch a
little bit of you know this show on
Netflix or whatever um so what can help
a lot of people is to set an alarm for
your bedtime you have an alarm for when
you get up have an alarm that goes off
and it's like it's 10:00 p.m. and it
maybe you hit the snooze alarm and you
give yourself another 10 minutes but
have something that signals to you this
is your bedtime it's time to go to sleep
Apple allows you to do that on their
phones and I actually set that up but
they have a lot of because I started to
realize based on the time I get up on
the morning what time I need to go
through there in order to get seven
hours of 7:00 that was like oh my god
yes I really need to go to bed a lot
earlier yes I think for a lot of people
do the math and figure it out and then
really do give yourself to bed time
because for children we're very aware
that they need at bedtime and we try to
really keep them to that bedtime
but a lot of times adults are like well
I'll go to bed as students I'm tired but
then they do things to kind of
artificially we do things that
artificially wake ourselves up mm so we
really should have been in bed two hours
before so just a final thought as as we
we wrap this up and everybody has lots
of ideas on Facebook the title of one of
your most popular books The Happiness
Project the word project oh yes that was
controversial
why well some people said oh project
sounds like too much work
sounds like homework and I was like oh I
love our project I think a Happiness
Project sounds fun but to me what it
resonated is is that it's something to
work on yes yes
yeah it's an idea it doesn't come just
organically it's not something you work
on by all the choices we make in our
life talk about how we spend time with
our friends how we spend time with our
family our co-workers our choices affect
our happiness absolutely and I think for
many people just realizing that there
are these little choices that they can
make they can really have a surprisingly
significant boost in happiness well
Gretchen Rubin thank you so much for
joining us and what's what's the name of
your new book that's coming out out or
order intercal and that comes out in
March okay hopefully you'll come back
this yes I hope so so fun to talk to you
really nice to talk to you thank you so
much
make friends on Facebook